foreign
[Music]
talking about how GK and Cloud run can
help accelerate application development
so
I am in charge of product for both
serverless and kubernetes joining me
today is Darren who leads product for
serverless and we also have the pleasure
of Brian and Corey joining us from Etsy
where they're going to tell the real
story versus the Google story of what
their experiences are with containers
now it's really hard to believe that
it's been over 20 years since Google
created Borg and our own container
management system we've made huge
strides during that time period let me
go ahead
hold on one second we've made huge
strides during this time period and
kubernetes itself is over 10 years old
at this point it's hard to imagine what
people did with containers before that
point outside of Google during this time
period we've looked at automation we've
looked at efficiency we've looked at
security such that all of you don't have
to take care of that that led us to
actually add autopilot mode where much
of the work is done by Google for you
still the flexibility of the kubernetes
ecosystem and even before that we
actually pioneered with Cloud run which
is the easiest serverless offering in
the market which Stern will be speaking
about later today as well now one of the
things that we're actually most proud of
is the fact that you have Choice you're
not locked into either kubernetes or one
serverless product we have the options
of cloud run which gives you the ability
to get going with containers incredibly
quickly now containers for many people
moving from Legacy VMS or older on-prem
systems where your build systems may be
a little Legacy or long in the tooth can
be really challenging this is where we
found customers have accelerated that
Journey with Cloud run because it's
opinion with locking you into a
traditional pass it allows you to get
going quickly Additionally you can scale
up to handle any workload possible and
one of the cool things we'll walk
through is how easy it is to actually
move your containers from cloud run to
gke or from GK to Cloud run
now on the flip side if you don't want
or if you do want to use kubernetes GK
is a great option for you so Cloud run
is a really fast way to get going
containers all up and we're seeing more
and more customers actually stay with us
and grow large-scale deployments like
Ikea and others but for gke our Focus
has been one make sure that we actually
practice what we preach in terms of our
investment in open source for instance
in the last 60 days we've made more
contributions to kubernetes than many of
the leading Cloud vendors have in the
history of kubernetes and this is really
where chopping wood and carrying water
and doing the hard work and enhancing
the products based on feedback from any
of you make a fundamental difference in
terms of our implementation just being
easier beyond that if you look we've
actually really heavily optimized for
new AI workloads they AI as you may have
heard maybe one to fifty hundred times
and that is a number this morning
has really changed the game but
kubernetes is a really good fit for this
but once again one of the struggles
we've seen is that people don't want a
Swiss army knife of options they want to
be able to grow to any sides but they do
want opinionation such you can get going
with gpus or tpus or any of the leading
AI Frameworks very quickly and that's
what we're investing in on kubernetes
right now and lastly is auto scaling ha
and security these are all things you
don't want to have to build yourself and
worry about so it made it easy to do so
now one of the coolest things recruit
for cloud run is actually how easy it is
to get a container going from having
that container to live in production
fully serving traffic so we've got a
nice little demo and thankfully to
Starin and our crappy Wi-Fi across
Moscone so apologies for that we've got
this preset up but Cloud run takes care
of all that heavy lifting for you it's
very very good with handling your
traffic splitting getting it fully
deployed and it literally seconds you're
live with either your new iteration or a
brand new container and this has led to
a lot of companies from the smallest
startups all the way to the largest
Enterprise in digital natives embracing
Cloud run because of this speed to
deploy and how well it ties into all our
development tools as well as the
ecosystem now Cloud run does have two
major strikes one is traditional
Services you may think about where it's
the way you really use uh Cloud run but
Cloud run jobs opens up a huge realm of
batch opportunities too because of that
great nature of zero one thousand and
thousand is zero and back down so I
encourage you to check it out more and
obviously listen to stare in a few
minutes
now near and dear to my heart I've
worked on gke and kubernetes for many
years now GK standard is the product
that menu and this audience use right
now one of the cool things about it is
the level of Automation and security
we've brought into it to make it a lot
simpler to actually get your cluster
going without having to do the work they
may have to do in other clouds of this
system additionally we have looked as I
mentioned looking at gpus and tpus such
you can run any AI workloads you want
and you can play the home game of
counting how many times we mention AI
today but it is all about Simplicity
every single point of friction makes
your life more difficult so our job is
to remove the difficult bits from
kubernetes and that's where we're
constantly looking for feedback from all
of you and lastly as I mentioned is how
do we have a secure really good single
cluster environment here now one of the
problems that you still have though is
what happens if you have more than one
cluster so quick show of hands how many
of you have one group one or more
community various clusters
okay how many of you have 10 or more uh
it's exercise it's four o'clock quick uh
show hands keep those hands up how many
of you have 10 or more
okay how many uh 50 or more
okay how many of you have a hundred or
more
a thousand or more I was gonna say I
know who's at a certain level for all
our clients but it's easy to manage one
it becomes really hard just like any
fleets like when we have VMS first come
out becomes harder and harder to manage
more and more this is also compounded by
the complexity of kubernetes and adding
all the add-ons so what I'm really
excited to actually announce TK stole a
little bit of my thunder this morning
but he's allowed that's his job it's GK
Enterprise Edition this actually Builds
on top of GK standard still all the
functionality you have within GK
standard right now remains with standard
edition no changes whatsoever but what
we've done is we built multi-team
multi-cluster management such you can
take a look at your fleets build an
observability build in security build in
compliance build and config all across
many clusters at once be it a one
cluster Fleet or literally in the
thousands with some of the customers
that we're testing right now
additionally of security and governance
and new functionality there looking for
vulnerabilities that's all being built
to look at one cluster or many
all part of this is actually all the
functionality we have within anthos is
now included as part of GK Enterprise
Edition so any of you using anthos for
multi-cloud hybrid or even on gcp all
functionalities not go away but is now
within one unified counseling experience
Within gke
what I'd like to do is actually welcome
up the
Etsy folks to walk through their
experience working with Cloud run and a
little bit of what they've seen within
GK so gentlemen I'll leave you to
introduce yourself my name is Corey
Samuels I'm the engineering manager for
Etsy service platform
we affectionately call the service
platform ESP so you'll hear that
referred to in the presentation today
I'm here with our Tech lead Brian Akins
and we're really excited to share a
little bit about our journey to design
and build a service platform for Etsy
we're going to walk you through the what
why and how of our platform and then
we're going to dig in to what we built
and some of the challenges and successes
that we encountered along the way
so let's start first by answering the
question why did Etsy need a service
platform
so prior to moving to the cloud in 2019
Etsy was primarily powered by a PHP
monolith that was in a Data Center and
because it was in the data center we
were constrained both technically and
Hardware wise as to what we were able to
build as the company grew the need for
services grew as well and moving to the
cloud enabled our Engineers to take
advantage of new service platforms where
they could put new Services outside of
this core monolith which still Powers
much of etsy's marketplace today
this Evolution to Services occurred
organically but very quickly we saw that
some problems were emerging we saw that
teams were duplicating infrastructure
and Scaffolding
service attribution was unclear
sometimes ambiguous we had no Central
service catalogs so Services weren't
easily visible or even accessible and
finally we had gaps in standards
operational process and support of
services
so to address these problems we assemble
the squad of Architects who spoke to
many teams around Etsy who were writing
services and ultimately the squad
created this Vision document which would
serve as the blueprint for how service
development would would uh what what
service development would look like in
the future
the core principle of this Vision was to
decouple service writing from the
infrastructure that the services ran on
this so this solved two problems for us
first it freed service writers from the
burden of infrastructure and secondly it
provided us a path to introduce
standards and guard rails into the
service architecture
thanks Drew and Corey hi I'm Brian Akins
but most everyone calls me Bacon's
slight bacon but plural I'm a senior
staff engineer and I've been at Etsy
since May of 2022 when I first started
at Etsy this Vision doc that Corey
mentioned had already been completed and
then the service platform Tina and I
joined was tasked with taking that
vision and making a practical working
service platform
uh from that Vision document after my
initial onboarding we discussed what
would be the success criteria for a
service platform we ask ourselves how
can we best spend our time and we ask
ourselves often like in a year if we
look back what would be a successful
um service platform we kind of came to
the very obvious conclusion that a
successful service platform would
enhance the developer experience to make
their lives easier seems obvious right
but we needed to dig a little bit deeper
like how would we know when we were
successful you know like how would we
know what we've reached at but then what
are the actual steps that we need to get
there
um so to do that very quickly we
conducted interviews and did small proof
of concepts with teams around
Etsy engineering including some of the
more operational focused teams because
we wanted to get that perspective as
well because we want to know what were
the day-to-day pains in both writing
services as well as supporting those
Services once they were in production
and we wanted like how can we
create a platform that would allow those
writing services to focus on their
business logic while providing the
operational Foundation that all
Production Services need so that would
also
make the lives of operators easy as well
and then finally how would this align
with this kind of architectural Vision
that came from a little bit from the
committee there became clear from
talking with people we had two basic use
cases that which are like hey I have a
great idea how can I quickly get that in
front of customers by integrated into
the Etsy product and that idea was
successful how do I support that long
term
we often say on the service platform
that an engineer's time and attention
are the most valuable assets that we
have at Etsy so we want to make sure
that we made good use of our Engineers
time so we wanted to be able to quickly
iterate
on the value that we thought that the
service platform could provide and
knowing that the entire engineering
organization was our kind of you know
potential Marketplace for this platform
and to do that we wanted to focus on the
Etsy specific parts of a service
platform we weren't looking to build a
generic service platform for all of the
world to use but for Etsy for our
engineering organization to
to use and maybe being fairly new to the
team I had to rely like say on a lot of
these interviews and talking with people
and
um doing that it sees a very kind of
face-to-face 101 type company so the
establishing those relationships across
engineering was very important for us to
get in there and hear their story like
what was it like when you launched
something how did that go what do you
wish had gone differently about that
so to do that we knew from the beginning
that we needed to use the highest level
service by Google or other providers
that would allow us to focus on that
Etsy specific part of the service
platform we didn't really have the time
nor the people we're a fairly small team
to make a whole lot of upfront
infrastructure decisions and
implementation before we actually dove
into the actual work of building the
service platform
while we're big fans of offerings like
gke which we've mentioned already by
using a platform like Cloud run they
were just entire classes of problems and
decisions that we just didn't they
didn't have to make you know whether we
like that opinion or not it was just
something that we could start with and
sometimes just deciding takes a lot
longer than the actual doing so we got
to start off much quicker
abstraction layers are obviously hard
but we wanted to do our best to make
sure that we didn't expose too many
low-level details to our service
developers so that they could focus on
writing and supporting their business
logic
so we generally don't have a strong
culture of
technology mandates specifically in
terms of platforms at Etsy so it was
very important for us to take that into
account when we were figuring out our
strategy of how we were going to design
and build this platform
we could build something that we thought
was perfect but if our Engineers who
were going to be our future customers
weren't sold on the platform
adoption would just be difficult and the
project could fail
so our approach around this was to First
assemble a team of Engineers who had
skills both in infrastructure and
application development
after that we put three things in place
first to make sure that we stayed
aligned to that architectural Vision
that we were given we composed a small
sort of Advisory Group that included two
of the original architects who had
authored the vision and we met with them
weekly to discuss implementation and
design details of the platform
second to ensure that we stay true to
what our customers actually needed we
partnered with one of our teams our ads
team
because they were already writing
services and they were a perfect fit for
what we were planning to do so one of
their Engineers actually rotated into
our team and helped us build an MVP
build and design the MVP and then our
Pilot service was one of this team's
services that they were planning to
build outside of the platform so that
aligned really really well lastly we
adopted a very flexible and adaptable
roadmap strategy so our teams work on
platform features and support would
align with what our customers actually
needed our service writing teams
so our MVP was lost launched at the end
of last year and then we followed that
soon after with the launch of our ads
team pilot in q1 of this year
so now that we've given you some
historical and sort of strategic context
of our service platform let's take a
look at what we actually built
so ESP at its core
it's a group of components that we've
glued together into a cohesive service
development experience
for our developer interface
we chose to write a custom command line
tool and that integrates really really
nicely with our CI CD workflow which is
powered by GitHub action
for communication we standardized on
grpc and we use protobuf for the
serialization format
Etsy Engineers use a pretty Broad
number of languages and to help you know
get adoption going we wanted to support
as many as we were able to
so on the service side we support go
node and Python and then on the client
side we support
languages that are needed around Etsy
ecosystems like PHP Java Scala Python
and node
so those clients are automatically
packaged up versioned and then
registered at artifactory and then all
of the services are cataloged into our
service catalog using backstage
finally Google services played a
critical role in these components of our
platform
all of our observability tooling is
powered by Google cloud services
and most importantly all of our services
are running on cloud run
before the launch of ESP of the service
platform each of these boxes you see and
actually the links between each one was
and a decision that a development team
had to make the decision and actually go
and Implement that
technology to support that and often
they would do this for each service that
they supported and since teams are often
fluid as you know this led to you know
like many many different ways to deploy
services without much standardization as
Cory had said earlier it's like we
wanted to avoid a one-size-fits-all
approach however we didn't know they
were key
features that we needed to uh
enable the general life cycle of the
services and to support the developers
workflows and since we didn't want to
use the build it and they will come
mentality because they never come when
you build it we used our Pilot service
and our partner team in the ads team to
like Drive the priorities and
requirements for at least initial phase
of the MBP we wanted to make sure that
we were actually building something that
our users would actually use as Corey
said we wrote this command line tool
called ESP that's the primary way in
which developers interact with a
platform is really a wrapper on top of
other tools as you can probably imagine
and it's just there to provide a
consistent kind of CLI
interface rather than having to know you
know 10 different tools and everything
and it provides
common tasks for like creating new
Services as well as working with
services that already written it does
things like it handles your Proto uh
generation so where you generate your
code from protoc files and it also
handles like run into service inside of
a container locally like you would do it
in Cloud run so that you can
I have a similar experience but it also
is used to run unit tests locally and
those types of things
it also generates uh language specific
uh container build so developers never
really have to deal with Docker files uh
and so we're able to make those best
practices and they're particularly where
work will like our application security
team to make sure that we get updates
injected into the platform without
having to go touch you know 10 different
uh repos the service platform also
provides a small framework for each
supported service language we call this
the runner because we're or at least I
am very terrible at naming things we
utilize code generation a whole lot
sometimes for better or worse but what
this framework does is allow enables
developers to be able to focus on just
writing like their service methods
without having to worry about things
like setting up observability uh
you know like setting up a grpc server
figuring out what port to listen on you
know like very mundane things but these
are things that if you've never written
a service if you're starting from
scratch that you have to do there's a
good bit of ceremony involved it also
provides us a base level of
observability out of the box so you get
pretty good you know like metrics
logging tracing and those types of
things without doing anything you know
within your service
Beyond writing your business logic
one of the things is we wanted to do
this is this why so that a service
developer can focus on writing the code
implementing that idea like we were
talking about earlier
but having best practices for
operational and infrastructure baked
into the platform so that we provide
pretty good guard rails for most use
cases just out of the box we use this
same command line tool in our cicd
pipeline so the same tool that you're
running tests locally that's what's
running tests and CI CD for you that way
we just have some consistency between
the two hopefully this gets rid of those
cases where like you've always had that
flaky test in CI but it works fine
locally so that's one of the things we
try to address I'm not going to say
we're 100 successful because you never
are but it also handles other things
like actually building the container as
ultimate generating Docker images but
also actually pushing that to a
container registry deploying it to Cloud
run and it automatically handles like
the
promotion from development to production
environments for example
um
we also generate what we call batteries
included clients for each one of our
supported client languages so
a consumer is generally working with our
generated clients and not like the kind
of raw generated grpc clients if you've
ever used those but we also we say it's
batteries included because we include
such things as service Discovery so like
if I'm working in a development
environment on service a and I need to
call service B it automatically knows
how to contact the development version
of service B without me having to tell
it it also provides instrumentation so
automatically get all the good you know
timings and logging Inception handling
and that kind of thing out of the box so
as a consumer I don't need to put that
in there it also handles environment
aware authentication so once again if
I'm in development it knows that I
should use my development credentials
and if I'm in production to use those
production credentials and if I'm on my
development VM which is kind of the way
that Etsy does a lot of our development
work it knows then to use that set of
credentials we use cloud run native
features authentication and
authorization so that was another case
we're like using Cloud run we just
didn't have to worry about that
implementation or that decision and it
was already it was just an easy button
for our apps seg team to just look at
it's like oh you're using IM we're good
um all services that are running on the
service platform are automatically
registered in our service catalog what
that does is obviously gives us a
catalog hence the name but it also does
some interesting things like we get some
base level documentation like we get
links to the Run books for the service
who owns this what's the on-call
schedule what are the links to the
dashboards but we also do things like we
Auto generate like a nice version of API
documentation from the protobuf files
and so you can kind of think of the
service catalog page for a service it's
kind of a at least an initial hub for a
service so that I as a consumer can go
look at that or if I just need to know
more information I'm going to at least
go there and it links out to other
things we also use that same service
catalog to where um
integrating that with other services
that are not necessarily in the service
platform so that that can kind of be the
one place stop place because as you all
know if you don't have at least six
documentation repositories what are you
even doing
all the Etsy systems like over here
um they use these generated clients to
call out to services so all those great
things I said about the batteries
included there that's what they do is
for example if I'm working in PHP and
the Etsy web monolith which is what we
call the like main Etsy uh product like
I just work with like high level PHP
objects and don't really have to worry
about the
implementation details I might even know
there's a such thing as a service
platform and I definitely don't even
have to worry about knowing that there's
a thing called Cloud run
just so that you don't think that we're
going to get up here and say all
positive things about Cloud run and
Google Cloud I wanted to at least give
you a couple of uh
uh challenges that we had that we had to
work through and some of these are just
obvious in hindsight as things like this
always are but we wanted to highlight
them shortly after we launched this ad
service
we overloaded a VPC connector for those
who don't know within serverless to
contact with other parts of the Google
infrastructure particularly those things
like a kubernetes cluster or services
that run there you go through this thing
called a VPC connector which Theron is
going to completely hate my description
of this I'm sure but basically it's like
a proxy server that's a really bad
description of it but it runs on VMS and
everything uh and we just completely
destroyed ours uh because we had done a
a huge amount of load testing
and everything looked fine but it turned
out when we actually turned on this
feature in the Etsy website that user
interaction like actual users like
people sitting at their computers and
buying and selling things was completely
unlike what we had modeled before as
users always are so we wound up going
down different paths that hit much
heavier endpoints and so we had to
quickly you know kind of on the Fly go
and make some dedicated VPC connectors
just for these services
services that we launched after our
Pilot service just because we kind of
need a Pilot service you know inside and
out by that point they were a little
trickier for us to determine what was
the best mix of like CPU and memory
allocation versus user traffic versus
concurrency particularly with all the
languages that we had involved and since
in Cloud run you're running in kind of a
container and it's you can't really get
a shell you can't really use like the
traditional like operating system tools
that we're used to using like on a
virtual machine so that's where we like
heavily instrumented all of our
applications and we work with the
development teams to do this because
they were the experts at their
applications and everything and then we
took things that made sense we actually
pour those back into the platform so
that everyone would
have access to those
it's like everything in a service
platform as I said we use uh Google IAM
so everything is TLS and uses layer 7
authentication we don't rely on a lot of
like private networks or anything there
but not everything in Etsy does that a
lot of uh older systems at Etsy which
are the money makers were lifted and
shifted from the data center as Corey
said
um so we've actually been working with
the Google serverless networking team to
determine what's the best way to get a
performant but secure like connectivity
from service to Service as well as
service to infrastructure without
exposing a lot of like low-level details
to developers and our ideal use case and
this is still ongoing we want them to
just State I need this kind of
connectivity and this kind of security
and we figured that out in the service
platform
um another uh instance that we had which
um like all the Google services really
helped us get started very quickly uh
like particularly the observability
tools because they're just kind of baked
in with Cloud run and they just work out
of the box you just automatically get a
ton of metrics logs and traces however
whenever one of our Engineers gets paged
at like 2 A.M as you inevitably do or
whatever they're used to working with
like grafana and if they're doing ad hoc
things like we're using promql for
things so we actually did a little bit
of kind of glue work with a Google
managed Prometheus and alert manager so
that we could actually expose all those
metrics both the kind of like Cloud run
native ones that come out of the box as
well as all the custom metrics that
we're doing that we could expose those
into familiar
interfaces to our service developers
another thing uh
is whenever we first started using Cloud
runs sidecar support was I think it was
maybe alpha or even like a private
preview only and so we were not
comfortable necessarily using that and
we use open Telemetry for all of our
Telemetry logging observability and
everything and in general the way that
you do that is run a little agent beside
your code but if you can't run a sidecar
you wind up accidentally invented in a
knit system which is what we did and
another thing that we do is we also run
a proxy which is named the entry point
because remember what I said about me
and naming things but what it does is
give us a common place for functionality
regardless of the language that we're
using so one thing that we're able to do
in the entry point for example is we
actually can do transcoding from like uh
Json to grpc so that we can expose
things to like more you know web-based
endpoints that's also another thing that
we needed to launch so we actually wound
up making this kind of monstrosity
that uh made sure that all these uh
processes were launched and injected
these additional binaries into the
server
um
containers as we were working since that
time thankfully uh
Cloud run side a car support is much
better and we've been working with that
okay whenever we uh first began working
with a service platform we focus more on
the day two which is kind of the care
and feeding of uh existing services
uh because we already had a very engaged
development team in our ads team and we
already had a Pilot service picked out
so we you know really didn't need to
spin up that many services but since
then we've actually done a whole lot of
work to work on that day one
um
thing like I have an idea and I want to
test it with Etsy and so we built the
sandbox environment and kind of like a
paired down version of the platform if
you will so I can go from absolutely
nothing type espnet which is how you
create a new service and have a
shareable link the something deployed in
gcp in about five minutes or so so not
too bad and that includes CI CD and
observability as well
most things have just generally worked
for example after we launched the ads
palette and we got over our VPC issues
they more than quadrupled the amount of
traffic going to this service by using
it in more places around Etsy which was
great we didn't even really notice like
Cloud run auto scaling just worked I'm
not going to say it's always going to do
that but in this particular use case it
worked really well for us
we have
um some requests for things that do not
nicely fit into the
serverless model and so we're actually
working with Google and our internal gke
teams to actually extend the service
platform to work on a more traditional
gke platforms as well because we want to
provide the same consistent like
developer experience regardless of the
runtime and speaking of that Stan's
going to talk to us a little bit about
how you can use gke and Cloud run
together
thanks Brian that's right I'm going to
tell you how Etsy and all of you can use
both Cloud run NGK together
so first let's recap you heard it from
Drew what's claudulin
allows you to deploy and scale
containerized apps in a fully managed
environment
so it's simple it's automated and
there's no cluster management to worry
about Google does that for you
and yes Brian we heard you VPC
connectivity could be better so that's
why we've launched a few weeks ago
directvpc no more serverless VPC
connectors in the middle your Cloud run
Services can just directly send traffic
to your VPC Network simple
and we've also launched recently
sidecars support for cloud run so
notably with sidecars that can help you
bring an observability side car like
open Telemetry or from Google manage
Prometheus
check out those two new features of
cloud run I'm a big fan of them
so now
Cloud run and gke many customers have
moved workloads between Cloud run NGK
from N2 and actually we've designed
Cloud run to avoid login and to enable
portability we've designed it that way
from the beginning
so obviously the portability is enabled
by cloudron ngke supporting the same
software deployment artifact the oci
container image the same image can run
on gke on cloud run on your local
machine anywhere containers are running
there is nothing proprietary about Cloud
run in a container that you deploy to
Cloud run
but we didn't stop here chlorine goes
further than that
chlorine is not using kubernetes under
the hood but it's V1 API is designed to
enable portability with kubernetes
and so the cloudron API actually share
the same structures and attribute as
kubernetes so in this simple example you
can see the similarities between your
kubernetes deployment and a cloud run
Service as you see most Fields look
exactly the same and the diff is just a
few lines
so now I'm gonna tell you about how you
can use both together in three ways how
you can manage them together how you can
secure them together and how you can
bring them together in the same data
path
so on the consistent management side
first there is a product that is called
Cloud deploy Cloud deploy will allow you
to do continuous deployment to both
Cloud run and gke managing environments
and parallel deployments Canary
deployments code deploy does all that
next if that's your thing you manage
Cloud run services using Cube control
to do that you would need to leverage
something called called config connector
but you can use Google control to manage
Cloud run if that's what you want to
then when it comes to built-in
observability those who runtimes have
built-in support for logs into Cloud
logging you can browse browse your logs
from cloud on NGK in the same place you
can observe the metrics from cloudron or
gke in the same Cloud monitoring
dashboards and you can even Define
service level objectives slos on your
Cloud run services or your gke services
and see them in a centralized location
with SLO monitoring
and finally
you can as we mentioned enforce policies
or collect Telemetry using the exact
same sidecars on cloud run and on gke
so that's about management what about
security
sorry
so both Cloud run and gke have the
notion of workload identity
a workload identity is basically an
identity you give to your services and
that determines what it is able to do
and you can use that for the least
privileged security design
you can
check containers for
vulnerabilities both cloud and gke will
scan your containers and surface those
vulnerabilities in context of those
products
you can enforce a central binary
authorization policy to decide if
container images should or shouldn't be
deployed to either Cloud 1 or GK
depending on things like have they been
scanned who has tested that image
and finally you can put all that within
the same
VPC service control perimeter
when it comes to networking
with the global or original application
load balancer
you can serve some endpoints on cloud
run and some endpoints on GK from your
user's perspective they are they're
coding the same domain it's the same
thing except that some requests will go
to Cloud run some will go to gke and
actually that's how you can move between
cloud and gke invisibly from your end
users you can from one day start
shifting traffic from gke to Cloud run
from cloud run to GK even gradually
thanks to application load balancers
as I mentioned you can directly connect
cloudron services in your clusters VPC
and you can even give private IPS to
Cloud run Services by using an internal
load balancer
so that's how you can use cloud run NGK
together
but now a question that you might have
is for a given workload for a given
service what run time should I pick
and you know what we like to say is if a
workload is a fit for cloud run which
means that it is an auto scale service
or a batch job we like to recommend
starting with Cloud run and if it's not
a fit Peak GK
as I mentioned we can always go back and
forth easily later if you need to
so we like to think that cloning is the
best way to get going with containers
and that we've enabled using Cloud run
and gke together
that wraps it all talk thank you very
much
we will be taking some live questions if
you want to at the mic right here or you
can catch up at the end
we are we'll be around
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign